where in the world who are you really
you can call me Carmen a new generation
of young my favorite show I'm excited
for I mean it's just it's I feel like a
roll like that and for for the things
that Gina's doing in this day and age in
this business is kind of I feel like
revolutionary you know she's not only
she's not sitting back and waiting for
the the hit of her show to garner her
work she's gone out not only creating
work she's finding projects that are
right for her other women people of
color using her power to develop that
and give those people opportunities and
for so long so many people in his
business has been given opportunities
and they just sat back and waited for
Hollywood to give them a job and to see
someone of her age of her experience to
go out and make that that's us dope and
a property like that that's such a big
property for her to go and grab it and
make it real I mean is so easy to sit on
your hands and become complacent and I
feel like so many people say there
aren't any opportunities and we don't
get this and we don't get that well
goddammit what happened if you get up
make your opportunities like that's dope
that's what little girls need to see
that's what little boys need to see
[Music]